and this is joint work with my students
Matthew and Seth and with our excellent
postdoc teaming so we've heard a lot
about different models of interactivity
and local privacy at this workshop let
me give you a quick sort of pictorial
representation of what they mean before
saying a little more formally so you've
got your devices and this is similar to
the slide that I already had this
morning except to you apparently better
idea than me about what the cloud looks
like sort of informally if you're non
interactive what that means is that all
of the communication can be fully
paralyzed ok so everyone's device looks
at their own data runs some local
randomizer and simultaneously can send
all of the information to the server ok
on the other hand we could ask for a
more general model the sequentially
interactive model that was defined in
Duchenne Jordan and Wainwright and
informally it looks like this now
information is sent sequentially to the
server and the message that the AI
person sends the randomizer that he runs
can depend on the previous messages that
were sent on the previous outcomes but
what you cannot do is go back to someone
who is previously queried and ask them
another question ok so in particular
only and messages are sent then finally
you can have the fully interactive model
in which there are essentially no
constraints so people can send messages
in any order there's no limit to the
length of the protocol in particular
each person might end up sending many
many many messages ok ok so I was gonna
leave it at this but something I didn't
realize before attending this workshop
is as a community we apparently don't
agree on what the definition
privacy in the local model so let me
tell you what I mean by it and and it's
somewhat I mean something somewhat more
general and more permissive than some of
the other talks we've heard so far okay
so first of all because the main thing
that I want to talk about in this work
is sample complexity to make that make
sense I'm going to assume that there's
an unknown distribution D from which all
of the end points are sampled iid okay
and in fact because I'm gonna be
thinking about reductions that might
increase the sample complexity of
various problems sometimes be convenient
to think about the algorithm as having
sampling access to D when it wants to
query a new person I can just you know
sample a new person from D and so when I
say sample complexity you know like what
you should think about in this talk is
how many times I have to sample a new
person from this distribution okay so a
local randomizer is just an epsilon
differentially private algorithm of a
single data point okay we can talk about
the set of all local randomizers and a
transcript which is sort of the complete
record complete observable record of an
interaction I'm gonna think of it it's
just a vector of four tuples where you
know each four people records what
happened at a single round okay so the
the thing recorded in one of these
fortunes is an index I of a user who was
asked a question okay a local randomizer
RT what question were they asked a
privacy parameter epsilon T okay that's
really a property of the local
randomizer but I'm gonna talk about it a
lot so let's just you know redundantly
include it in the transcript okay so RT
is epsilon t private and then there's YT
which is the answer the user gave YT is
a sample of the output of the local
randomizer applied to the data of person
I T
and the thing that will coordinate a
local product yeah
it will coordinate a computation in the
local model is a protocol in the way I'm
thinking of a protocol is it's going to
take as input a transcript a record of
what has happened so far and it's gonna
decide what happens next
okay so given a record of what's
happened so far it will either decide
that the protocol is over okay or it
will decide what to do next which
corresponds to choosing the next person
it's gonna ask a question to what
question it's gonna ask them and what
privacy parameter that question will
have so here's you know like some
pseudocode just making clear the you
know what happens when you have a
protocol and you run it okay so okay
we've got our end users and now for some
number of rounds that if I don't specify
the mechanism is sequentially
interactive could be arbitrarily large
the number of rounds could be much
bigger than n will you know for each
round we will let the protocol look at
the transcript of what's happened so far
okay it might decide we're done in which
case we just output the transcript or it
might decide we're not done in which
case it tells us you know okay I'd like
to ask person IT a question and I'd like
to have them run local randomizer RT
it'll have privacy parameter epsilon T
for this talk ignore Delta and and then
we'll we'll have user I T run the local
randomizer on their data point that
gives us a white t and that's the next
next entry in the transcript and we
continue okay so when I say that I think
that uh when I define what it means for
a protocol to be epsilon differentially
private in the local model what I mean
is that this algorithm when instantiate
with a should be differentially private
okay that's the thing that this
algorithm outputs is the transcript okay
and so the this this running of the
protocol which Maps data sets to
transcripts that could be differentially
private that's what I mean okay
this way that one of the individuals to
interact with is not allowed to carry
stage they don't need to sit so the way
I'm thinking about things is the
protocol is just talent you know the
protocol carries all over the state
that's necessary
but you could allow the individuals to
carry stick
I guess your definition still seems to
allow something that logical behavior
for example your protocol could say ask
the same person twice or differentiate
by base version of their answer and of
course we won't agree then you may find
my privacy completely and that would
still the users to behave arbitrarily
rather than that's I mean all users
other than me should be allowed to
behave up friendly alright are you
asking sort of like a about a difference
between like an honest but curious model
or an adversarial a I'm not sure I
understand but the party has epsilon T
equal to infinity in there it's open
what one user wouldn't let me alone
violating privacy for another user so in
general I'm gonna yeah like we require
that you know like with probability yeah
this algorithm has to be differentially
private epsilon differentially private
and all of the users so it sounds like
what you're describing wouldn't be Oh
so here the fact that I get privacy can
depend on the fact that you are honestly
executing your protocol because your
randomness is kind of inbuilt in here
right but we would really want it to be
the case that even pure completely
dishonest you're worried about people
not running the the randomizers yeah I
don't think I think you could well we'll
see as I go on I don't think anything
I'm gonna say would would break under
that model but you could generalize it a
bit but a lot of the things I'm going to
talk about our about sample complexity
and you need to specify some you know
somehow like what it means to get like
more samples so that this is the sort of
most straightforward way to talk about
that Xfire in them for the first leg
that follow experiment doesn't take the
data as an input yeah pretend it takes
the data as the input for now so yeah
the privacy should be for all pairs of
neighboring data sets so here I think
technically in this definition my
privacy depends on the fact that all the
other people not only follow their
protocol but don't observe the output of
the randomizer what do you mean don't
observe the output of the randomizer
that's part of the science room
oh wait
okay okay so in this in this model we
can think about three kinds of
interactivity fully interactive means we
essentially have no restriction on what
this protocol looks like the length of
the protocol can be arbitrarily large
sequential interactivity just means that
for any user there's at most one index
in which they are the ones queried okay
so in particular the number of rounds is
the most n and a non interactive
mechanism is a special case of a
sequentially interactive one every one
sends that multiple one message but now
the local randomizers can all be chosen
in parallel
okay the choice of person is local
randomizer doesn't depend on the outcome
of the other
so between fully interactive and
sequentially interactive that's the
nasty thing that happens in the first
one so in a fully interactive mechanism
I could ask you a question I could ask
canola question then I could come back
to you I could keep doing this the
protocol could run for a really long
time
you could imagine defining things into
20 going rounds of every round it's a
protocol like everybody is exactly my
rent my local randomizer is always that
slim VP for that particular round yes
then we'll talk about the connection to
your definition of local differential
privacy yes
okay so we've seen in a bunch of talks
that there's there's a lot of advantages
to non interactivity in particular often
communication is a bottleneck and since
non interactive mechanisms can be fully
paralyzed that's great
sequential interactivity loses that but
it has its own advantages in particular
it's much more powerful so we've seen in
both Batali's talk on Thursday and
hybrid Yves talk from today and other
good work that there can be exponential
gaps between the sample complexity for
solving natural learning problems when
you go from non interactivity to
sequential interactivity okay and
there's other advantages the protocols
are still relatively short to only add
messages and you don't have to go back
and locate specific prior users so if I
get on an airplane and turn my phone on
airplane mode it doesn't like break the
protocol and so one thing I want to
think about is you know what are the
advantages of full interactivity where
there's a bunch of disadvantages but
like perhaps we get even more power so
we can think about is the fully
interactive so not a lot is known about
this so many of those sort of powerful
lower bound techniques including those
developed in the seminal work of DG
Jordan Wainwright for proving lower
bounds in the local model for
interactive protocols they hold only for
sequential interactive protocols and we
saw a talk by John on on Tuesday well I
watched it on video I wasn't here but
any of you saw it in which and work
together with Brian Rogers they were
able to extend some of these lower
bounds to a subclass of fully
interactive mechanisms in the way I'm
defining them okay to show that there
are certain non interactive mechanisms
that are optimal within this restricted
subclass okay it wasn't known as far as
I know whether you get additional power
by moving into full interactivity one
working also one of the places that
excellent yes well we'll see how Epsilon
yeah there's other nice things about
that paper that you know so let me let
me tell you about what we do and then
we'll see how much of it we can get
through it's the first we just sort of
find some parameter that turns out to be
useful for categorizing fully
interactive mechanisms that we call
their compositionality okay I'll tell
you what that is on the next slide but
this is sort of a extremely relevant
parameter and roughly the definition
that the Ryan use is what we would call
the set of one compositional mechanisms
okay so here's our upper bound we show
that if you have any K compositional
mechanism that's actually fully
interactive we can generically compile
that into a sequentially interactive
mechanism that exactly preserves the
transcript distribution okay so it
solves whatever problem you were solving
just as well such that the blow-up and
sample complexity is only on the order
of okay or e to the epsilon times K so
bigger if epsilon is big and that means
that if you have a one compositional
mechanism then there's nothing you can
do with a fully interactive protocol
that you can't do with a sequentially
interactive protocol the next result is
that our dependence on this parameter is
tanked like this is actually an
important parameter okay and this is
also I think the first separation
between fully interactive mechanisms and
sequentially interactive ones so in
particular for every K we identify a
family of problems that can be solved by
a K compositional mechanism with some
sample complexity n which depends on K
such that if you wanted to solve this
problem with a sequentially interactive
protocol you would need a factor of K
more samples okay so you can imagine
reductions that have you know different
dependencies on other parameters that
you can generically give a reduction
that has a better dependence on this
parameter which I'll tell you what it is
knowledge and then finally we have some
stuff to say about hypothesis testing as
well so in particular for any simple
hypothesis testing problem or more
generally for any compound hypothesis
testing problem we're both the know and
the alternative are our convex closed
under mixtures then you don't need
interactivity at all the optimal tests
even amongst the set of arbitrary
interactive mechanisms is in fact not
interactive okay so let me let me tell
you what with this compositionality
means because that's sort of the the
crucial parameter that underlies our
work here okay
so let's say that an epsilon private
protocol is K compositional if when I
look at for any single user the epsilon
parameters of the local randomizers that
I asked them to run okay so the epsilon
parameters corresponding to a single
user okay
they add up to at most K times the
overall privacy guarantee of the
mechanism okay and if K is one let's
just say that a is compositional in fact
we only really need the pit holds on
average so in fact if I just sum up all
of the privacy parameters used over the
course of the mechanism it should sum up
to the most K times n times Epsilon so
one compositionality is a pretty natural
subclass if you've analyzed your
mechanism with the composition theorem
for a differential privacy just by
adding up the Epsilon's then you get a
one compositional mechanism okay and
it's related to the classic mechanisms
that that john and ryan prove lower
bounds for roughly speaking they're
proving lower bounds against what we
would call one compositional KL stable
mechanisms okay so on the one hand we're
gonna sort of generalize this to allow
hey beer on the other hand we really do
require differential privacy KL
stability is not enough for us so um
it's natural like compositionality is so
natural that you might conjecture the
first time you think about this that
like everything is compositional right
the privacy parameters add up so it's
like helpful to see a simple example
demonstrating that that's not the case
like there are k there are mechanisms
that are not K compositional for
arbitrarily large K okay maybe here's
the simplest example which is related to
the analysis and rapport okay so let's
suppose that the data universe consists
of the stant the D standard basis
vectors in some D dimensional space so
your data point has a 1 in some position
and a 0 everywhere else okay and
remember what randomized responses if I
run randomized response on a bit then
you will put that bit with probability P
the epsilon over 1 plus e to the epsilon
otherwise you'll flip the bed so now
just what I'm gonna do is for every
person and for a record inant I'm gonna
ask them to run randomized response on
purpose and I run randomized response on
coordinate J if they're fit with privacy
parameter epsilon okay so every person
is running D local randomizers each of
which really is epsilon differentially
private and it's not DEP Salon prime
differentially private for any smaller
epsilon because there really is you know
like a neighboring data set that changes
the probably
a bit that you're gonna output by you
know Andy to the epsilon factor and yet
because of histogram structure
essentially that if you change to a
neighboring point you only change two
coordinates of the vector this protocol
isn't d epsilon private it's to epsilon
private so this protocol fails to be
cave compositional for any K less than D
over 2 and we can take D to be as
largest we want so it's not it's not
that it's not that one compositional
mechanisms are all there is ok one
compositionality compositionality is
what you get if you only analyze your
algorithm using the composition theorem
but there are algorithms that have non
compositional analysis let me let me try
to tell you how the upper bound works
how we get from full to sequential
adaptivity with a blow up in sample
complexity that's bounded by K and it's
based on sort of three ideas
so the first one is really you know not
an algorithmic idea this is about
thought experiment okay we're gonna like
look at our protocol we're gonna imagine
that it's actually a slightly different
pretend protocol but it's going to
induce exactly the same transcript
distribution so for the rest of the
argument we can try to simulate the
transcript distribution of this pretend
protocol then we're going to sort of
simulate to the distribution of this
pretend protocol with a sequentially
adaptive protocol basically using
rejection sampling and Bayes rule okay
I'm gonna go through all of these in
more detail
this step will get us to sequential
adaptivity
but it might really blow up the sample
complexity okay and so the third step is
to slightly generalize this very nice
idea of a data independent decomposition
of local randomizers that Borja told us
about on Wednesday which allows us to
shrink the sample complexity back down
okay so the sample complexity of the
mechanism that we get here is gonna blow
up from whatever for from n to roughly T
the number of rounds the protocol ran
which could be really big but the third
step is gonna get it back down to e to
the epsilon x and x okay okay so that's
the high level overview so let's go
through these one at a time here's sort
of the pretend mechanism it's almost
exactly the same as the regular
mechanism with one change okay so this
is sort of a beige and thought
experiment so what's really going on of
course when we run a locally private
protocol is we sample the data then the
data is fixed once we start running the
mechanism I'm gonna you know be asking
people questions when I go back to ask
Adam another question it will you know
it'll be the same atom that I asked the
first question to okay
but why don't I imagine that that's not
what happens when I go back to a time a
question for the second time I actually
resample his data afresh not from the
prior distribution not from the real
data distribution but on the posterior
distribution 1 conditioned on the
transcript I've seen so far okay hey I
don't know what this posterior is it
might be hard to think about like
resampling atom but like it's something
I can imagine and it just sort of by
Bayes rule or maybe even just the laws
of conditional probability it's not too
hard to see that no outside observer can
tell if I was doing this recently or not
it doesn't change the output
distribution on transcripts or in
general if I have any pair of sort of
jointly distributed random variables
that can sample X and I can sample Y
conditional on X or I can sample X
second sample Y conditional on X then I
can resample X conditional on Y and I
get the same direct distribution that's
all we're doing here okay so our target
can be to simulate the transcript
distribution on this thing okay right
now every time before I ask someone a
question I resample their point from the
posterior okay
now I don't know how to sample from the
posterior okay but I do know how to
sample from the prior right I can ask a
new person I can sample a new person
from the distribution and I can ask them
a question right that's the kind of
thing I can do with sequential
interactivity so the idea will be to try
to do rejection sampling I've got a
sampling distribution this sort of data
distribution the thing I'm trying to
simulate is also sampling a new person
every time it asks a question but it's
sampling from the posterior distribution
on the transcript okay so okay the idea
that we want to implement is whenever
it's time to like ask Adam another
question I'm gonna sample a new person
okay then I will ask them to employ a
reduction sampling and if they succeed
then it will be a sample from the
posterior and I'll I'll continue okay so
for rejection sampling what like what I
would want to do right if I want to
sample someone from the data
distribution conditions on the
transcript but I can only sample from
the data distribution is I would want to
accept with probability proportional to
the ratio of the density of the
probability of x given the transcript
divided by the probability of X now
there's a problem which is that well I
at the protocol but more importantly the
individuals running the local
randomizers don't know what these
quantities are and either the numerator
or the Dominator because we don't know
what the prior distribution is and so we
don't know what the posterior
distribution is but we're sampling rate
like it's nice that like the thing in
the numerator is a posterior and the
thing in the denominator is a prior that
means I can apply Bayes rule and get an
equivalent expression and now the thing
in the numerator is something that the
user can calculate given just their own
data and the transcript so far what's
the probability that they would have
generated the responses recorded in the
transcript and attribute it to them
given their own data point okay the
thing the denominator okay we still the
probability of the transcript we still
don't know how to calculate that thing
because we don't know the data
distribution but it's data independent
okay and so we only need to sample with
probability proportional to this so I
can rescale this by any data independent
quantity and so it suffices to have
people accept with probability the
probability that their part of the
transcript would have been generated
given their data point divided by twice
the maximum probability over any data
point they could have had that their
part of the transcript would have been
generated with that data point that's
something that those are quantities that
they can compute with only the
information they have on hand
so okay so this is nice we can do the
rejection sampling the users can do the
rejection sampling with only information
they have on hand the transcript and
their on data points its epsilon
differentially private to perform the
sampling because the fact that the
transcript was epsilon differentially
private allows us to bound the ratio of
the prior to the posterior so this
number is going to be that the 2 is
making it sort of the two is important
for differential privacy so this number
is going to be something that's bounded
that that's you know between 1 and e to
the minus epsilon it'll be bad if it
were 1 and it usually 60s or it succeeds
with constant probability if epsilon is
a constant right it's this sort of
success probability is 1 over 2 times e
to the epsilon so whenever we whenever
our original protocol wants to ask
someone a question okay like wants to
run a local randomizer on you know run
another local randomizer on Adam okay
we use this rejection sampling routine
okay we're going to now until until
someone passes the test
keep sampling a new person from the
distribution ask them to compute this
probability which they can do from their
own data
ask them to sample from a Bernoulli
distribution with this probability which
is epsilon differentially private and if
they pass then we ask them the local
randomizer to employ the local
randomizer we want it to run otherwise
we sample a new person but it won't
it'll it'll pass with constant
probability
okay so where have we gotten so far with
this idea the upshot is that we wearing
is that we can exactly simulate the
transcript distribution of a fully
interactive protocol now with a
sequentially interactive protocol but
our sample complexity might really have
been blown up oh but before we get there
our privacy cost was potentially blown
up by only a little bit right it's blown
up because now when someone successfully
passes the reduction sampling step I've
asked them to answer two differentially
private queries basically the rejection
sampling cost them potentially epsilon
and then I ran an epsilon T local
randomizer epsilon T is going to be less
than Epsilon so by you know composition
in the direction in which it works this
is only 2 epsilon private ok the big
problem is that the sample complexity
has been blown up because now I'm
running you know there's t rounds to
this protocol T could be very big and
I'm asking each local randomizer to a
new person whereas you know the fully
interactive protocol was asking each
person on average T over n questions ok
so I don't know all right so I've blown
up the sample complexity from n to 2
times e to the epsilon times T right
because now I'm asking everyone sort of
T questions that it potentially takes me
an expectation to times e to the epsilon
people before I find one good enough to
answer a question ok and this is bad
because I don't know a priori how big T
is it could be arbitrarily large so we
need one more idea ok and this is where
we're using the idea of the data
independent decomposition from Borja at
all ok so so we clean it it's like
generalization of their theorem but let
me first remind you of their theorem
okay so what they show for a very
different purpose is that if you've got
an epsilon private local randomizer you
can in fact write it as a mixture
distribution where there's two mixture
components ok Omega is a data
independent district
okay and then this other component DX
this does depend on the data but the
weight on DX is small
okay so almost all of the weights weight
of you know e to the minus epsilon which
when epsilon is small you should think
of as 1 minus epsilon is on the data
independent part okay so nice and it
sort of is at least suggestive of a way
that you could sort of reduce sample
complexity because so you know only with
some small probability do I actually
need to look at someone's data in order
to answer a question that I have to ask
them the problem is that if you you know
like oftentimes this data dependent part
of the distribution is just like you
know like a point mass on their private
data it's just you know tell me your
private data and so for the protocol to
like for the local randomizer to be
private although it has this
decomposition it's like really crucial
for the privacy that it not become
public which of the realized mixture
components I sampled from right that's
really crucial because this distribution
could just be announcing your data in
the clear okay
so we need this generalization because
I'm you know once once you once you see
what they do it's not too hard to come
up with this generalization okay here's
what we can say suppose you've got an
epsilon prime private randomizer R and
now why don't you pick some epsilon
which is bigger than epsilon prime okay
I can decompose your randomizer R and to
again a mixture of two distributions
okay one of them is gonna be data
independent the other of them will be
another local randomizer okay where the
local rant this local randomizer will
have a privacy guarantee this local
randomizer will be epsilon private which
is less private than the original
randomizer which was epsilon prime
private but the weights that I put on
the epsilon private local randomizer
well it looks like this which is easier
to interpret twin epsilon and epsilon
primer you know kind of small lists but
one it's roughly epsilon prime over
epsilon okay so by making epsilon bigger
I can reduce the probability that I need
to actually talk to a person in order to
answer their question in order to have
them answer a question but increase
their privacy costs in the event that I
need to talk to them okay and now right
like now I can get privacy a worse
privacy Epsilon instead of epsilon prime
but I can get some privacy guarantee
even if I reveal publicly which part of
the which mixture component I'm sampling
from okay and you can trade off the
privacy cost with the probability of
needing data so so now here's the idea
okay
remember we've already gone from a fully
interactive mechanism to a sequential
interactive mechanism okay but the
sample complexity is really blown up but
now okay we're gonna run that
sequentially interactive mechanism and
every time the protocol tells us to run
an epsilon T private local randomizer
we're gonna publicly flip a coin okay
and with roughly probability 1 minus
epsilon T over epsilon it's going to
tell us we can sample from this
nation in by sampling from the data
independent distribution we don't need
to you know actually sample another atom
and which case we want sample another
atom will be able to get YT which we
need to continue the protocol without
without expending another sample okay
with the remaining probability epsilon T
over epsilon we actually do need another
person in which case we will use this
slightly less private randomizer our
Tilda used through our rejection
sampling routine okay
and again when the Epsilon's are small
I'll show you that we have you know all
of this stuff generalizes to when the
epsilon sorr big but the bounds are more
messy when the epsilon is small the
probability that I need to sample a new
person is roughly epsilon t over epsilon
and so if you look at the expected
number of users that I need to actually
sample right it's the sum over all of
the rounds of the privacy parameter of
the local randomizer at that round
divided by epsilon and if the mechanism
was k compositional that's K times n ok
right because Cate compositional means
the sum of the epsilon T's is at most
epsilon kN
like if we're to apply this to the
example you gave earlier of this
histogram so what this is there's an
equivalent protocol where in all but one
round I just make up the answer myself
and then just like one round I talk to
the user but being that round to ask her
like a much more accurate answer that's
right and sort of distribution will
Jenna this will generate the same thing
right this is like some generic way to
like trade off like you have an existing
protocol I can like trade off privacy
with sample complexity
see he put it all together what do you
mean in general like actually some if
you are yeah if you recognize them as
compositional then you might as well be
almost always sending data so you can
put it all together and it looks like
that but it's really just these three
ideas each of which is pretty playful
here's the theorem in the end okay for
any fully interactive epsilon private K
compositional protocol there's a
sequentially interactive protocol a
prime that is 3 epsilon privates
produces exactly the same transcript
distribution as the original protocol
and with high probability has up to
lower terms sample complexity that's
like the original sample complexity
larger by a factor of K and E to be
epsilon okay so in particular for
compositional mechanisms if K is 1 then
okay and you know up to this factor of e
to be epsilon any lower bound you prove
for sequentially interactive mechanisms
also holds for compositional fully
interactive
and this is tight I only have eight
minutes but let me try to show you the
problem that is sort of hard for
sequentially interactive mechanisms but
is easy for K compass for K
compositional fully interactive
mechanisms okay and it's a variant of a
pointer jumping problem so we imagine a
tree okay there are levels of this tree
I know it looks like D is 4 but trust me
it's D and imagine that at each level
the vertices are labeled with a bit
called left or right okay and let me
name for you know at a particular level
I I will call Zi just the vector of the
labels of the vertices at that level
okay so once I've labeled the tree like
this it induces like a unique root to
leaf path down the street
so call something like this when I
assign you know these labels to every
vertex in a complete binary tree an
instance of the multiparty point you're
jumping problem now I want to turn this
into a problem that we can ask a locally
private protocol to solve so let me
define a distribution from which people
are going to be drawn okay okay I'm
gonna so given an instance Z Z is the
labelings okay I'm gonna define the
following distribution first select a
level of the tree uniformly at random
and then output the data point that is
the pair equaling the level of the tree
and the labels for that level of the
tree okay so get so any so people when
you sample a new person from its
distribution they have a level at random
and they get all of the information
about that level of the tree all of the
people at the same level have the same
information okay but it's private what
level you are and the problem right the
problem we want to solve is given n
samples from this distribution find the
path
so we have a separation so first claim
is that there's a decompositional fully
interactive mechanism that can solve any
instance of this problem with sample
complexity that's in the order of d
squared over epsilon squared okay here's
how it works
and here's the first question I'm gonna
ask it says if you are at level one then
use randomized response to tell me your
child okay if you are not at level one
just flip a coin and tell me a random
bit to the right I don't know who's at
level one and who's not that's part of
the private data so this is the
description of a complete local
randomizer if you're at level one you
run randomize response if you're not at
level run you just flip a coin okay we
try to identify from that and we're
gonna rig things up so that we can with
high probability what is the sort of
correct child then I'm gonna call the
child P to another local randomizer
again I asked in in each of these rounds
I asked everyone to run this local
randomizer so it's fully interactive
people are answering many questions if
my level is are I learned the entire
that entire layer right now that's one
you if your level is is yeah are you
learning like I'm like it's the whole
it's the whole layer exactly okay so the
second round I yeah the second round
hopefully I've learned sort of the first
edge down this tree and so now I ask you
know okay if you happen to be at the
second level then tell me who your child
is with randomized response if you're
not at the second level again I don't
know who is and who's not flip a coin
okay we're generally I'm gonna continue
in this way and assuming we've succeeded
up until now I'm gonna ask you though at
the L throned if you're at the elf level
report the child of pl with randomized
response if you're otherwise photocard
okay so so how do you think about
analyzing this protocol well first you
need to argue that you have enough
signal to like correctly with high
probability identify the child you know
that you were going to correctly build
up this path one at a time okay
so you know if an is not like something
like d squared over epsilon squared how
many people are at each level well the
probability that you're at a level that
particular level is one over D okay so
roughly there's roughly n over D people
at each level and that works out if
you've picked this to the end to be root
n over epsilon people at each level and
root n over epsilon is just at the
threshold of you know the kind of signal
you can distinguish from the noise
that's introduced by randomized response
when you have n people okay I can
estimate like a thumb when I've got n
people up to error roughly root n over
Epsilon
okay so that's we've rigged things up so
that like that's exactly the level of
signal we have until we can like
correctly identify the child at each
step
about the privacy analysis well each
user is running an epsilon private local
randomizer D times one for every level
of this tree but embedded in here you
will recognize is the histogram
structure of the example I gave at the
beginning of the talk right because
every person is only at a single level
and so will only have to answer in a
data dependent way once even though I've
asked D questions particularly any
sequence of responses thanks sequence of
bits has probability that's bounded
between 1 over 2 to the D minus 1 times
1 over e to the epsilon plus 1 and 1
over 2 to the D minus 1 times e to the
epsilon over e to the epsilon plus 1 so
even though the epsilon T you know your
epsilon T's add up to D times epsilon
the whole protocol is actually epsilon
private okay so it's paint compositional
epsilon private kick off there couple
case D okay I just have two minutes left
somebody like give you some intuition
for the lower bound which is that any
sequentially interactive protocol
actually requires a factor of K more
samples here k is d right it was that d
k was a was D in our prevent
construction and so that's gonna turn
into a lower bound that says you need d
cubed over epsilon squared samples if
you're sequentially interactive the
actual proof is is a long delicate
induction but I think the intuition is
pretty straightforward which is but even
even identify a single edge even till
even at the top level you really need
like d squared over epsilon squared
examples and that's because like you
really can't estimate a sum in the local
model to air it when you've got n people
to error better than root n over epsilon
okay so okay so like you sort of need
root n over epsilon people at the
relevant level but each you know when I
sample a person the chance that they're
at the relevant level is only 1 over D
so to guarantee that you're gonna have
that you sort of need n over root n over
epsilon people ok which means that you
sort of need d squared over epsilon
squared examples
to answer this question at each step but
if you're sequentially interactive you
can't reuse people after I've used
everyone to answer the first question I
need like a new sample to answer the
second question and a new sample to
answer the third question okay that's
that's not a proof but but that's maybe
the intuition for why this problem is
hard for sequential interactive
mechanisms oh let me just tell you since
the amount of time our theorems for
hypothesis testing but not tell you
anything about it optimally local
optimal locally private hypothesis tests
for simple hypothesis testing are not
interactive okay so you get optimality
even with respect to to the entire class
of fully interactive mechanisms you can
generalize that a little bit to compound
hypothesis testing where both the null
and the alternative are closed under
mixtures or convex okay and you can ask
me that there's a proof that's not in
the paper because we ended up proving
something stronger but maybe like a less
interesting way so you can actually
offline if you want to get this result
just for compositional mechanisms then
you can have sort of a neat little
reduction using amplification by
shuffling which I so thank you
[Applause]
so in particular the what that says is
the kind of body of work that's been
built up on lower bounds for non
interactive and sequentially interactive
mechanisms give so for those simple
testing problems where there are tight
upper and lower bounds then those those
bounds are also tight through that kind
of fold that's right and we're generally
yeah any lower bound you've previously
proven for sequentially interactive
mechanisms also holds for one
compositional mechanisms and we're
generally holds for K computational
mechanisms up to some loss it's like a
factor of potential EK yes definitely
the most interesting special place the
most interesting special case of this is
the simple testing yeah great question
so I think that's the main open question
coming out of our works so what we
showed right is that there's this
parameter K that is sort of crucial
right if you have a cake compositional
mechanism you can get a sequentially
interactive mechanism with a blow-up
with a factor of K and you can't do
better than that in terms of K now our
lower bound instance which shows that
this dependence on K is tight never
results in a blow-up that's more than a
factor of square root of n so you might
conjecture and I do conjecture that you
can simulate any fully interactive
mechanism with a sequentially
interactive mechanism that uses only n
to the three-halves samples you can't do
better than that because our lower bound
also shows an end to the three-halves
bound in terms of n but I kind of you
know due to some not very well grounded
intuitions believe that's the right
answer
do something similar through the
simulation in the SG model something
similar to what the simulation desk
model also would give you translation
from any into the SP model then you can
sing right back so in a sense you can
begin with what any and through this get
back into is going so I don't Adam
probably not a better answer to this
question yes sir certainly as written in
our paper I don't think you'd get
anything like we had some blow-ups in
terms of brown complexity and things
like that that I think would end up kind
of boiling down to assuming
I'm not quite sure not assuming
compositionality bit like we were
missing like certainly missing the
really crucial idea that you know you
can do the decomposition doesn't seem
like a somewhat generic way to like
reduce sample complexity if you are not
making like really tight use of your
privacy budget
what about the input to give me that not
for me yes so so it's not clear how you
would even or wasn't clear to us at
least how you would even hose that
question because you know the form of
the results we find is that there are
some problems that need like more data
to solve so the question is if there's
not a distribution from which the data
is drawn what does it mean - like solve
the problem with like larger sample if
you have a protocol that many times is
essentially the more than one so so
basically it's not if if the mechanism
is compositional you know like if I
think a lot of this would generalize at
least in the case where you don't really
need to blow up the sample complexity so
the one compositional case - symmetric
like mechanisms that are sort of
permutation invariants like it is sort
of important that like a priori all of
the people be sort of the same because
the whole thing that we're trying to do
is to avoid asking the same person
multiple questions and to instead like
ask those questions to different people
so it does seem like you need some kind
of symmetry at least but I think a lot
of this would go through for permutation
invariant mechanisms at least like for
the one come when you start needing to
blow up the sample complexity of like 4k
compositional mechanisms it's not clear
what that means if you don't have a
source from which to gather more data
that's a good question
so so it's related to the question that
I guess you talked about the open
problem session which is when we can get
when is it that we can sort of reduce
epsilon-delta privacy to Epsilon privacy
and maybe you know more about this than
me
it seems like the existing like the only
thing the existing proof is using about
like sequential interactivity is like
that there's only n randomizers and so
like at least for fully interactive
protocols for which T was polynomial in
n it seems like you could do the same
thing and you'd need Delta to be smaller
than something in T okay so it seems
like that would be almost immediate that
that if four protocols for which the
rounds complexity was polynomial and and
all of this should go through up to some
log T factors also for epsilon Delta but
I don't know if there's like something
more subtle that goes wrong with that
reduction we didn't work it out
yeah in the rejection sampling stuff
since your conditioning on the
transcript there's an assumption that
you know what the randomizer can't be
hidden from you need to be able to
account for an air conditioning is that
yeah but even to implement even to run
the randomizer around the data you need
to know what it is right like what is it
what do you mean the randomizer is
running the reduction sampling is also
happening in the local one where you do
the reduction sampling right you need to
know what the data point is only the
user knows that not the protocol is
available your you have a full
transcript available locally yeah
everyone can observe the transcript you
have you see the other but you see other
randomizers as well you see the output
of the other end I mean the protocol
like you design the protocols you could
just had that information with it thanks
guy yeah like the whole point is that in
the end like the thing that should be
differentially private is the whole
transcript so like everyone can see the
track
[Applause]